dans le domaine de la santé nous manques
sont assez criant aujourd'hui dans un
pays comme la france
alors est ce que c'est le résultat de la
réduction des budgets publics ou comme
vous auriez peut-être tendance à penser
de la gratuité générale des soins
je crois que les deux sont un peu lié
c'est à dire que à partir du moment le
la santé publique a été pilotée par la
gratuité on a forcément la mise en place
d'un système de rationnement et un
ajustement par la baisse de la qualité
des soins et il a encore je pense qu'on
n'a pas suffisamment réfléchi ce qu'on
vend aux etats-unis c'est-à-dire le fait
qu' il est très important qu'il y ait
une couverture universelle de la
population et ça c'est important
évidemment pour les individus mais aussi
pour la santé publique
à l'inversé l'idée que tout soit gratuit
pour tout le monde et pour tous les
soins
ça c'est une idée qui n'a aucun sens au
plan de la temple et qui n'a aucun sens
sur le plan de la solidarité qui n'a
aucun sens sur le plan économique
et c'est vrai que c'est politique de
rationnement ont entraîné une baisse de
la qualité une baisse de la qualité des
soins et une organisation des soins sur
le mode de la pénurie
c'est aussi ce qui explique par exemple
cette aberration qui a été la
suppression des stocks stratégiques de
masques puisqu'en 2012 on va aller
encore plus d'un milliard de masques en
stock et que ce stock a été réduit à 145
millions au début de la crise ce qui
explique que très rapidement on se soit
retrouvé dans une situation de pénurie
criante et que parce qu'on n'avait pas
de mac
on a prétendu qu'il n'était pas utile ce
qui est évidemment et malheureusement
chasse qu'est ce qu'il faut
[Musique]